et nous sommes avec patrick karam 10
président a l'air de la région ile de
france et auteur du dictionnaire mondial
de l'islamisme publié chez plon
bonjour patrick karam merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france dont vous
faites partie de ceux qui estiment que
ce projet de loi ne va pas assez loin
pour quelle raison il ya quelques
avancées mais il y a énormément de
manques il y a en fait neuf péchés
capitaux neufs péchés capitaux qui va
être un véritable problème par la suite
pour le gouvernement d'abord je constate
qu'on n'a pas nommées d'islamisme vous
regardez le texte je n'ai vu à aucun
moment contrairement aux déclarations du
président de la république faites aux
mureaux le 8 2 le en octobre 2020 à
aucun moment
nommé le mal deuxième élément alors on
peut me dire que c'est pour ne pas
stigmatiser les musulmans je dis
attention à ne pas confondre islam et
islamisme et en refusant de citer
d'islamisme c'est la réponse un stigmate
is l'islam et les musulmans deuxièmement
il ya un sujet majeur
c'est effectivement ce qui porte les
tendances qui sont déviante
les salafistes les frériste et les
tables il établit ses 7,7 islam
m indo pakistanais à aucun moment à
aucun moment on travaille sur cette
question il fallait rendre illégal ces
tendances de l'islamisme qui aujourd'hui
pollue pour lui totalement à la fois le
débat public mais contamine le reste de
la société
il fallait en banque illégal ces
tendances là et en conséquence fermer
les mosquées
sur cette base là arrêté de tourner
autour du pot
arrêtez de vouloir fermer des mosquées
sous des prétextes mais nommé le mal et
puis fermé en conséquence les mosquées
dissoudre les organisations et faire en
sorte que ceux qui revendiquent une
telle ou telle aspiration ne puisse pas
être dans la fonction publique
or aujourd'hui rien n'empêche ce que
feint frériste ont un salafiste et bien
pu cette fonctionnaire dans la fonction
publique puisse se retrouver dans nos
armées dans notre police ou ailleurs
quatrièmement il fallait refuser les
imams fonctionnaires nous avons 300
imams fonctionnaires qui sont des agents
de pays étrangers dont 150 qui sont
turcs 150 payé par la turquie et qui
sont aujourd'hui gérées par un
fonctionnaire un diplomate
un conseiller aux affaires culturelles à
l'ambassade de turquie ils prennent
leurs ordres directement d'erdogan et
quand il s'agit de contester nos lois ce
sont ces fonctionnaires turcs qui sont
dans les imams dans les mosquées où ce
sont donc ces imams qui sont en première
ligne
je considère que ne pas qu'on ne peut
les maintenir sur notre territoire est
une grave erreur
il fallait prendre en compte ce refus
d'accepter des imams fonctionnaires
c'est-à-dire payer par l'étranger et 40
de vous parler d'avancée quelles sont
ces avancées tout de même concernant ce
projet de loi il ya quelques avancées on
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure le délit de
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui par
diffusion ça c'est extrêmement important
le le fait d'étendre à l'ensemble des
opérateurs publics privés pardon ce qui
est à la fois remplissent une commande
publique ou alors en place une mission
de service public des obligations de
neutralité et de laïcité qui sied aux
fonctionnaires c'est une bonne chose
inscrit au fichier des auteurs
d'infractions terroristes la provocation
est là l'apologie du terrorisme est une
bonne chose mais il ya quand même aussi
d'autres manquent
nous avons aujourd'hui sur le fichier
fichier fs p art et vous savez le
fichier des signalé des signalements des
pour la radicalisation terroristes nous
avons huit mille personnes sur ses 8000
personnes 3000 étrangers
comment on peut continuer à dans une
partie qui ne n'ont pas qu'ils sont
effectivement sans document valable en
france
comment on peut les accepter encore en
france il faut immédiatement les
expulser il faut une trentaine d'agents
de police jour et nuit pour surveiller
un seul radicaliser si on veut faire une
surveillance 24 heures sur 24
comment on peut penser qu'avec
et 3000 personnes dont neuf mille agents
de police 90 mille agents de police on
pourrait y arriver
prenons le cas de la fonction publique
aujourd'hui cette fonction publique
aujourd'hui doit être décontaminé
rien n'est prévu là dessus et sur les
associations sportives
moi je voudrais dire une chose le pacte
en dix points qui vaut pour toutes les
assos et les assauts sportives et bien
n'est pas opérationnelle avant 2026
expliquez-moi comment lorsqu'on à mille
milles radicaliser terroristes dans nos
clubs de sport 1000cc le document
parlementaire
c'est aussi ce qu'indique mon livre avec
magali lac rose le livre noir du sport
mille personnes radicaliser qui sont des
dessertes qui peuvent être des des
pratiquants mais dans un club de tir ça
pose problème il peut peut-être aussi
des des éducateurs contaminer les
enfants ou des dirigeants
dites moi très calme alors que l'opinion
publique l'opinion publique et cette loi
justement il ya un parallèle qui est
fait avec la loi sécurité globale une
loi qu est jugée controversée contesté
dans la rue
ce projet de loi aussi sur les
séparatismes par anciennement appelée
séparatisme constitue aussi une forme de
contestation de la part de la rue là
est-ce qu'on pensez vous justement de ce
parallèle non mais pardon il ya des
parallèles ne pas faire d'abord moi je
note que l'opinion publique
ça fait longtemps qu'elle attend avec
impatience une telle loi
et je vous rappelle qu'il ya moins d'un
mois le parti majoritaire a fait
justement un sondage sur cette question
là et le gouvernement
et sur cette question invité à aller
très loin par nos compatriotes et ça
n'est pas parce qu'il y à quelques
milliers quelques dizaines de milliers
de manifestants dans les rues dont
certains sont violents dont certains
sont effectivement manipuler dont
certains ont pour objectif de contester
nos valeurs contester la république
détruire l'état détruire ces symboles en
s'attaquant à la fois la police à la
justice et en s'attaquant aussi aux
pompiers
ce n'est pas parce qu'il manifeste qu'il
faut forcément les écouter un état doit
être fort ça veut dire aussi me ramener
de l'ordre dans notre pays et la
sécurité de nos compatriotes et le
premier devoir d'un état c'est aussi
pour ça que nous payons nos impôts et
toutes l'acheter tout abandon tour of
skull
et bien c'est une trahison vis-à-vis des
obligations co gouvernement doit
s'imposer
merci beaucoup à vous patrick karam je
rappelle que vous êtes le président ait
l'air de la région ile de france auteur
du dictionnaire mondial dans libre
président libre à de la région
ile-de-france on précise et auteur du
dictionnaire mondial de l'islamisme
publié chez plon merci m